while the coronavirus pandemic continues
to affect many countries life in new
zealand goes on largely as normal
there hasn't been a case of covert 19
transmitted in the community since
february thanks to the borders staying
closed but from early next year the
government plans to reopen to vaccinated
travelers from low-risk countries
we cannot keep border restrictions on
forever and to be absolutely clear we
don't want to do that either and neither
do the experts we talk to
border closures were only ever a
temporary measure in order to keep
covered out before a vaccine was
developed and administered
but just days before the announcement
from the prime minister new zealanders
suffered a scare
dozens of unvaccinated workers at the
country's largest port were allowed onto
a ship that had come from australia
carrying covert positive crew
all the port workers tested negative but
it exposed a vulnerability in new
zealand's defence
new zealand has been able to stay covert
free for most of the pandemic because of
good management and good luck but what
happened here is a reminder of how
quickly things could change and when
combined with a low vaccination rate how
dangerous it could be
just over 17 percent are vaccinated one
of the lowest rates in the developed
world new zealand's prime minister says
everyone will be offered a vaccine by
the end of the year delta picks on those
that haven't been vaccinated or have
only had one dose
and who are they they're the young
adults the young adults have been
neglected with their vaccine
access
around the world including new zealand
and australia if there are further
outbreaks of the virus the government
says it will move quickly with an
aggressive lockdown there won't be zero
cases but when there is one in the
community we crush it
but while it's covered free and as many
people as possible are vaccinated then
new zealand's international isolation
will come to a partial end next year
wayne hey al jazeera tauranga new
zealand